today I'm speaking with Hillary Lawson
philosopher award-winning broadcaster
and the founder of the how the light
gets in philosophy and music festival
which aims to uh as it's put take
philosophy out of the academy and back
into people's lives uh welcome Hillary
I've been looking forward to our
conversation
and I am too good to see you soon
absolutely great so um how the light
gets in has now been going on since 2010
that was the first Festival back in hey
and each year you have a different theme
for the festival this year's theme is
error and Renaissance can you just say a
bit about what what uh prompted that
theme for this year yeah we we always
try and tie it in with what's going on
in some sort of more Global uh sense and
I guess
um there were a couple of political
events that had occurred in the previous
six months which certainly some would
see as an error one was with um
with Afghanistan but more critically
with the Ukraine and and the West's
[Music]
um
misunderstanding really of what was
going on with uh with Russia and so
forth and then that raised all sorts of
questions about our perception of the
West and uh how we were to understand
ourselves and so forth and so in fact
the the uh the initiation of the theme
was really driven by uh by geopolitics
rather than by a predominantly uh a
philosophical theme although it does
have of course philosophy at the heart
of it and the idea is that we would try
and identify things that where we have
either been thought to have made an
error or that there are some uh people
who would claim that we have made an
error and what should we do about it and
what possible future uh alternative
might there be uh and so we have applied
that to to all of the different areas
that we handle you know from science to
uh you know different strands yeah yeah
exactly right are there any uh sort of
specific examples talking about you know
rebirth and correcting these errors are
there any areas where you see some fruit
coming out of this uh maybe in the
geopolitics or in other debates well I
think we try to do that in absolutely
every every debate we put forward really
um we're always looking to see what
might be the uh what might be a step uh
forward in each in each area so I don't
think
um
uh uh it's quite quite difficult to give
a give an overall uh version of that we
could talk about individual works but I
think you give an example maybe we do
quite a lot in the science area of
course uh and we look to areas that
might be thought of as uh an error and
which we don't traditionally think of
being errors so the story about the Big
Bang
and and uh the immediate period after
the big bang which is the center of
contemporary physics uh is something
that
we look at in one debate which is about
really the issue of inflation
now uh Cosmic inflation is the notion
that after the big bang the the uh
Universe expands at an enormous rate and
it's a requirement of The Big Bang
Theory
uh that this happens because otherwise
uh the universe is much bigger than it
should be based on the calculations of
the the initial stages of the universe
so so inflation Cosmic inflation is is
proposed but most people don't realize
that Cosmic inflation involves the
universe expanding at many times the
speed of light
in fact orders of magnitude faster than
the speed of light
and we have a debate which is about
questioning whether this is a plausible
claim
and and should we uh should we be doing
something about it should we uh see it
differently is the very Story the
overall story of The Big Bang and the
origin of the universe in some way uh uh
flawed and should we be thinking of it
in a different sort of way altogether
and there are you know a plenty of
people who who think there are
alternatives uh to to that which take
account not not just a cosmic inflation
say that's a mistake but to paint a
different picture altogether of uh how
we might understand the the origin of
the universe but that would be an
example of we take something where we
assume that we know what's going on we
uh identify possible errors or mistakes
that we have overlooked or covered up
which we do all the time frankly
um in various areas of our understanding
and then look to see well what could we
do about this what how else uh might we
think about the issue right right yeah
so I think I mean the fact that you have
such a wealth of different debates on so
many different subjects
um you know what I might consider
science Politics the Arts Etc and then
what would normally get considered as in
the field of philosophy
um uh what prompts a thought about what
exactly you mean by philosophy do you
have this broad sense of in all of these
different things we're doing philosophy
or yeah how do you feel it yes so I I
mean there obviously is a question you
know what is philosophy yeah
philosopher's always good at looking at
their own Naval and and
um uh uh what does philosophy consist of
I'd simply take it to be our big
accounts of the world uh our big
theories
and that's our you know you know
person in the streets sort of sensitive
thing you know our philosophy is you
know how we approach the world what what
we how we understand it and and so we
are looking at those
um core Grand theories that drive our
understanding and that will be true in
every area so there's nothing a
philosophy in uh
in many
um
philosophy departments in in Britain and
North America is quite heavily focused
on uh either issues of language or of
the mind uh and so forth and so the sort
of sense of philosophies in that in that
context tends to become a rather sort of
smaller topic that that than the one
that we have which is to take any uh
idea which contributes to our overall
world view and think well what do we
think of this and what is driving it and
uh is it is it one which we want to
endorse or are there cracks in it that
need to be explored yeah great yeah I
mean that would that would explain also
the title there's a crack in everything
but and that's how the light gets in yes
of course that that typo is um
uh it is it fits what we're doing uh
very well in the sense that it actually
comes from a Leonard Cohen song for
those people who are into this sort of
thing I actually heard Leonard Cohen at
Glastonbury uh in 2008 he was doing his
um
his uh his final well the beginning of
his tour as it were and I imagined he
was going to be um
uh uh
rather uh sad figure of uh you know
trying to revive his uh early songs and
like a like you know a couple hundred
thousand other people I was in the crowd
and uh he was very remarkable in fact
far from it being uh being uh rehashed
material it was it was very impressive
and I I heard some of his songs really
for the first time and this one in
particular uh there is a crack in
everything that's how the light exit and
uh shortly afterwards we were you know
just beginning thinking what what might
we call the festival and I thought that
is very much the core of the idea of
what a philosophy should be doing you
know it should be trying to identify
where there are weaknesses in our
current thinking and as a result of
identifying those weaknesses see new
visitors of how we might hold things
differently
and do you think in the process of
identifying those cracks and amending
those assumptions changing them that
there's any kind of grander ethical
program or do you think that will help
make us better people or is it just to
expand our minds in some way what is
possible
well
I mean they simply think of the
connected yes I mean ethics is a strange
topic
um
strange in the sense that uh
um
it's so often used as a means of
justifying our prejudice so
you know parents do this with children
don't they they uh when when when the
child's ask them um teen times well why
do I need to do this well they just say
well you should do it
or it's right or um it's the good thing
to do or whatever
um and so I think that uh a lot of
morality is um
is a defense a prejudice
um
uh and have somehow bringing the
conversation to an end
so when saying you know are we doing
this in order to um make the world a
better place uh or sort of effort be on
the side of the side of good well
everyone pretends they want to be on the
side of good don't they that's just the
nature of the way they the vocabulary is
set up I mean uh only only in sort of um
you know Hollywood science fiction
stories to be how people are actually
against good uh so of course we uh think
that what we're doing is is is for the
betterment of people and and we think
that this is a a positive thing and
valuable and so forth but I would
hesitate to use these terms which I
think are
um uh are usually questionable
so for example if someone said you know
what's the value of public philosophy
you wouldn't want to put it in terms of
ethical
terms and if how would you describe very
reason that putting in ethical terms is
not answering the question it's just
saying well I like it and and
grandifying it with a with uh with with
an ethical word like good or uh orally
right or whatever it would be it's just
it's just calling on some other
authority to say that what you're what
you think is uh is valuable well I I
think most of that can go in the dustman
and we're not interested in that sort of
prejudice I think that what we are
interested in is exploring how we
understand the world and trying to find
uh ways that would enable us to do
things that we approve of
um and that we think would in a in a not
moral sense make the world a better
place what does that mean in a not moral
sense make the world a better place
well what does it mean to say in a moral
sense
what what is this other than to uh
um uh I mean this is Nietzsche's point
about God is dead isn't it you know that
that
um uh for a long time we relied on an
external Authority in order to uh give
ourselves uh meaning and a a
and understanding what we were doing in
the world
um but uh gradually our own
exploration of the world has uncovered
the
the limitations of that and and so
um
I think I I would feel much more
comfortable in saying uh there are uh
practical things that uh we can do or
achieve with our new uh philosophical
Frameworks rather than trying to appeal
to some
uh other authority which is what
morality seeks to do okay so then when
you talk about practical things
um those practical things are not to
achieve
some it's not what some Authority thinks
is good but those practical things
presumably improve the situation the
condition for other people which could
be seen as moral
could be seen as something in some basic
sense to be good even that if that was
not dictated by some moral code yes as I
say of course
everybody thinks that what they're doing
is is morally good I just don't like
wrapping oneself in the flag okay
yeah it's it's it's not attractive yes
okay it's not attractive the people
who've wrapped their fell self in the
moral frag are usually up to no good in
my view
um and indeed have been responsible for
terrible things
uh so we should be a bit wary of it
that's all
I think read carefully there are other
ways of describing I mean there are
times I'm sure when I fall into my my
own mistake and where and say you know
well we're trying to uh we're trying to
improve the body politic we're trying to
create a space where uh we overcome the
prejudices of our time we are trying to
you know all of these things
um and it's quite hard to to get rid of
that sort of moral language in defense
of one's judgment
um but uh I I just hesitate slightly uh
uh as as if one is achieving something
by saying oh yes we're trying to do good
of course we're trying to do good in
some fundamental way why who wouldn't be
right so we're gonna we can assume that
context but we're not going to uh Lord
it around
um
yeah and maybe maybe there's a bit more
going on in that conversation
um
because you know I I
as I say I think the that that that
moral discourse is dangerous and there
is a there's plenty of sign of it
returning so is it a difference between
expressing it to others and thinking it
so for example if you communicate this
is our program this is what we're trying
to achieve is that where you see the the
main dangers lying in imposing it on
other people through language I think
the main thing that's tricky about about
moral uh Frameworks
and indeed framework of right and wrong
uh which spreads a little bit further
than morality
um is that it takes the complexity of
the world and imagines that it is binary
and this is very dangerous
um
because it makes it look as if
all goods are the same and all bads are
the same and and you and you act on
those if you've if you act on those
simple categories
as I say you frequently end up making
terrible errors so I've just been wary
of them
and uh they're also used by people to
make themselves feel good
psychologically oh I'm good
I'm on the side of good Pat myself on
the back
show off to other people I'm good well I
don't like any of it
right so you but also presumably you
wouldn't want people to think I'm bad
either so they would need to move Beyond
these categories of good and badly in
order
in favor of uh hopefully a more
sophisticated sense of what one is
trying to achieve
and and whether people approve of that
uh or not that'll be based on all sorts
of complex uh judgments there
um
but of course we you know
you know almost everyone is a mode of
thinking that they're trying to do
something that they think is they
approve of I mean why would you try to
do something you don't approve I mean
the whole thing is sort of circular
But but so really I think that morality
stuff is is usually just
Shoring our power most of the time
trying to say this is why it's being
done and actually not only do I approve
of it but it is good
you know some other authority is coming
to my Aid here
I think we need a bit more humility in
the world than than that
and do you anything then intellectual
humility or humility about the truth
will best be achieved by recognizing
this complexity but then on the one hand
you have moral realism The View that
there are these mind independent moral
truths that there is a fact of the
matter that what is good what is bad
then you have moral relativism which
says it depends on each individual or
each culture or each context
um how would you Traverse that divide
um between those two or is it possible
to do so
of course you know I I'm I'm a
long-standing Critic of realism so um
long crowded criticism critical realism
in the uh uh in um in all aspects of uh
uh a reality you know material reality
and so forth so of course I'm critical
of the idea that there are moral facts I
regard the whole thing as being you know
farcical
um
uh at fosco and dangerous
and something that of course one has to
combat
um
you know for people who believe in moral
facts are thoroughly dangerous Folk
uh because they're not self-questioning
they are they imagine that the world
divides into these neat categories which
are human categories and they don't
um and uh it leads to terrible outcomes
like
um
you know killing people because you
think you're doing good for them or
you're saving them from uh evil or
whatever it would be
uh so yeah I think
[Music]
um
uh needs to be combated uh
at some serious level
great well yes this um critique of
realism you're expressing your book on
uh closure
um perhaps you could link that to this
talk of moral realism what does what
would closure Theory have to say about
moral realism why it's wrong oh the the
the you know I started out
um like I guess
many people as a student I I was at
Oxford I uh I I remember it well I was
uh I was fortunate to be taught by a
renowned uh sociologist called Steven
Luke's who've written a book about
relativism and I I rather lovely went
along at the beginning of the term said
look I want to get to the Bedrock of the
the foundation of knowledge I want to be
sure of where I am you know but that's
what I'm going to do and and he of
course indulge and touched me most of
them it's ridiculous I indulged me and
said yeah okay okay well actually he had
a last love because
um uh the more I looked for a Bedrock
the more I I uncovered our inability to
find one
um and uh I I was then faced with well
if we can't find a basis for what we
call Knowledge if we don't have a ground
as it were what do we do about that
and um I puzzled about that for a long
time I uh you know by the my early uh uh
uh Works were about the problem of
self-reference you know that if you deny
[Music]
um
uh truth or you draw attention to
perspective then
you can't express your view because that
applies to yourself as well you know if
you if you say there is no truth it's
presumably not true that there is no
truth as it were so uh so I I I I'm just
very much engage with that but I then
so well what you know what could a
possible
way out of this conundrum b a conundrum
which it seems to me is uh you know
the devil's Western culture you know
it's it's somehow the enlightenment has
led to a point of the undermining of the
of the
um solidity of knowledge as it were and
then the question well what do you do
about it
and uh because you can't seem to express
the position that that takes up and so
closure is about trying to provide a
framework to deal with that and I
started with what initially seems to be
a completely implausible uh position
um because I didn't you know I I
obviously when I was thinking I didn't
didn't know that I I could make make it
work at all I I just thought well let's
imagine that
instead of thinking that our thought and
our sinacies are somehow discovering a
reality which is out there which we can
uncover and which there's a like a
correct answer that that we're hunting
for the right answer as if it's like a
crossword puzzle If instead of thinking
of it like that if we think well
actually the the world is something
other than us it's not that it doesn't
it's not there but it's something other
than us and it's not
it's not divided into into the sorts of
things that we might discover it's
somehow different but in a way that is
not definable because if it was
definable then we could say how it was
different and uh in a way of trying to
no I I toyed with uh I mean Heidegger
has the issue of Crossing through beings
to to identify that you can't actually
refer to being that it's it's crossed
out uh because otherwise it looks as if
it's referring to something I toyed with
the idea of having something like worlds
crossed out as it were is what what this
was but uh I thought well that's that's
a bit of a cop-out
instead I went for the word openness and
said well let's imagine the world as
being open it has he doesn't have any
differentiation to it that's already
divided and what we are trying to do is
make sense of this stuff that is other
and the framework of closure is one
which
uh demonstrates I think that you do not
need
um to think that are
senses and our thought
are describing a reality in order for it
to be effective and useful for us to
intervene
and
once that once that is developed there
is then an account that there's then a
framework to escape this problem of
self-reference because the theory itself
can account for why itself it works one
of the examples that I give is that you
know when you look up at the stars
um you see all sorts of patterns
you know you can see Orion or
astronomers can see Hercules or whatever
it would be
but we don't think those patterns are
are really there do we I mean if we were
at different different place in the
universe their patterns would look
different and what's more
um there is an indefinite number of
patterns that we can hold the stars in
in fact even in an in just a hundred
Stars uh you uh you can create more
patterns than there are atoms in the
known universe so it's a spectacular
number of ways you can pattern those
times you basically find anything in the
past
so we don't think that any one of those
patterns is true
um and it's not in in some sense related
to reality because there's a an almost
infinite number that could be applied it
doesn't mean to say they're not useful
once you've identified a pattern
you can just point to the star that's
just to the right at the top you say you
see around well do you see that star
that's just above the one on the top
left hand side
so you can use it to point to something
else
you can track that pattern across the
sky
if you fill out the whole Sky which
people did in a medieval period before
the worm compasses you can use it to
navigate around the world
powerful
but nobody thinks that it's true
and and and it's not uncovering a
reality it's not somehow well it's
uncovering you know Iran is uncovering
something ultimate out there that's not
what's going on it's holding this stuff
which is other than us as something so
we hold it as a rhyme it's not that it
is a run we hold it as a run and so the
basis of the idea of closure is that our
senses and our thought are not
descriptions of the world they are ways
of holding the world and the detail of
closure is how it is that those ways of
holding the world enable us to achieve
all sorts of things
and the structure of how that works and
the structure of constraint that follows
from it as well of course
yeah great thank you very much for that
um over you Hillary uh just focusing on
this idea of of self-reference here and
and also you you're sort of talking
about usefulness more than truth if we
think about the problem of
self-reference presumably you would say
you don't want to say that the theory of
closure is true because then that would
get into the problem of it reflecting
some Ultimate Reality but you do want to
say that the theory of closure is useful
which is accommodated within the system
so right it's a little bit more a little
a little bit different from that so that
the framework of closure changes the
traditionally within 20th century
Western philosophy the the our
understanding has largely been driven by
words like language and the world
there has also been subject and objects
which sort of preceded it to some degree
uh and was then incorporated into
language and world to impart although
there were periods where those people
are in favor of language sort of try to
get rid of the subject at one point but
nevertheless
um we've operated with that that the
those words language on the world and
the dynamic of those words
the way that they operate
it's very difficult to escape this
self-referential problem
something that related against you know
identified you know he the end of the
tractatus concludes that language is not
able to provide a description of its
relationship to the world
um that's because it would somehow have
to catch sight of itself and it can't do
that
and so he abandons the very idea of ever
trying to make any overall story about
what what's going on because he's
concluded you can't do it
well
uh that's sort of related to this
self-referential problem that as soon as
you try to
stand in that language World story you
tend to get
linked into this
uh self-reference issue which I don't
think has ever been uh overcome
uh and
the reason that I chose closure and
openness is the way those two words
function is a bit different
so the relationship between closure and
openness is not the same as the
relationship between language and the
world
and what we understand by
um truth and reality is all rather
different in this
in this different framework So when you
say
um so uh would I say that closure is uh
useful well I would say the framework of
closure enables you to realize a way of
holding the world which
um
I think is powerful and enables us to
overcome many of the problems we have at
the moment
um
you might translate that out into a more
pragmatist language of saying actually
closure is useful uh
uh and sometimes sometimes I I would do
that
but
I hesitate slightly to do it in quite
the way that you were describing because
I want in a way to escape what seems to
me some of the
um
puzzles that are endemic to the truth
reality language which is the common one
in which we inhabit
and the way to do that I think is partly
to change the vocabulary
and it drops out rather differently
right and and usefulness also drops out
well I
[Music]
um
within within the frame of closure I I
think that our closures are ways of
holding the world that's the phrasing I
use yeah
um and I think that they they realize
material that is they realize things
so when we when we close the world when
we see Orion we have something we didn't
have before
it's not as if it's there in the first
place through closure we have something
in addition
we don't it's not like we've just
identified a pattern that's there we
actually create that pattern in some
sense it does there is constraint to
what we can create but we we we realize
that pattern and we hold the world as if
it was like that
we hold the world as if Iran is there
they even know itself evidently isn't so
so
um
uh so that process of of realizing
things
which goes on in in in at least
linguistic closure of realizing things
is the way that we are then able to
intervene
um and now that intervening you know
stress losing some of the language of
usefulness or taking away from the
language of the info and talking about
practicality but not necessarily about
the consequence as well all right well
yes so I would say you you intervene in
again and the puzzle is what we how we
can intervene yeah and of course there
are then you know a whole load of other
bigger puzzles about the way that we try
to manipulate that intervention and the
way that
um uh
um
our theories function
and are used to
change what we can do
[Music]
and and
in some broader sense that's tied up
with
um
the
political function of theories that is
the extent to which they are able uh to
influence others
and how we try and influence others
uh how we try and get as it were our
closures adopted by other people
none of which is to say that your your
overall point that you were making it at
the beginning but
would I want to say closure is
is true
um uh uh
you know you you're right in one sense
that I obviously don't want to say
closure is true in a realist sense but I
but I do want to say that
I think it's the most
um effective story that we have of the
world at the moment which is uh quite
enough it's already a bit of a grandkid
so so uh but I I wouldn't I wouldn't
want to say that it's true in the sense
of it is the one way of holding the
world yes because
um
yeah yeah well and and
um and of course in practice nobody has
come up with a story which is true in
that sense which everyone then holds to
be the case but nevertheless
um
you you're right
uh about that right thank you um well
unfortunately we're gonna have to come
to a close now I still have many more
questions we could continue going on
this route for for quite some time I
imagine
um but uh yeah we're good to have a
sense of where you're coming from and
also the the broader philosophical
picture behind the festival just as a
just as a final look I think that
one of the one of the strange puzzles
about the issue of truth and reality and
where we are currently in society is it
does seem to me that
the enlightenment uh has in the last
hundred years somehow undermined itself
that it had this idea of gradually
uncovering the truth about the world and
we have somehow uncovered our inability
to do so
and that that puzzle I think has it's an
intellectual puzzle in in in in one
sense but it's also become a a broader
you know puzzle for the story of the
West in a wider sense in in a political
sense
and it that that played out I guess in
in the form of post-modernism uh and the
greater Place modernism in the late late
20th century and it has played out most
recently in public life in arguments
about
um
uh truth in the in in public discourse
and and and the alternative truths and
so forth
and so I think these questions of the
the our relation to reality are not are
not little sort of technical or
interesting philosophical puzzles I
think that they are absolutely Central
to our understanding of both ourselves
and our place in the world
and I think
um
I do think you know we have to get to
grips with it uh and uh the in in the
early part of the 20th century in in
Britain and North America there was a
virtual focus on the the puzzle as we
were saying a relationship between
language and the world and and people
were really engaged in trying to build a
story if you like a metaphysics of how
that worked and so forth and what's
happened to I think more recently is the
difficulty of doing that and getting
success as it were
um has sort of gradually led to it being
it being sidelined it's just been too
difficult you know where we can't work
this out so we'll just get by we'll just
carry on as if as if the whole problem
isn't there
um and I I don't think that is a viable
thing to do uh and indeed at the moment
I think that that that
um culturally we're making exactly the
wrong move so
so
yeah I vote dude
um and argue that we have to give up the
idea of there being a reality that we're
uncovering or that we can arrive at
truth
but
I don't think that we give up the tools
that we have to improve our models and
stories and what I would describe as
closures by which we realize uh the
world that we live in and those tools
are the good Enlightenment
um principles of empiricism and
rationality
and both empiricism and rationality I
think have had a big bad press over the
last 50 years of post-modernism as it
were and there are many people who are
you know skeptical of of both would see
it as being Western Colonial male
um white and so forth and and and and
yet
those very same people are are often
attached to the idea of there being a
truth you know their truth so they're
attached to the idea of truth but they
abandon the the the techniques of the
Enlightenment of empiricism and
rationalism uh or or or or challenge
them and
it's the wrong way around
I would argue that we have to double
down on empiricism and rationalism that
is looking to see whether one's closure
looking to see whether one's theory of
the world works
um seeing where it doesn't trying to
refine it and so forth identifying where
indeed there are errors and thinking
about how one might create stronger and
better accounts of the world
um and rationalism is part of that as
well following through the consequences
of uh a system uh uh uh of uh thought in
in one area and seeing how it applies
elsewhere those are essential tools
but we just have to give up the idea
that they are going somewhere that they
arrive
at a sort of they are uncovering uh an
ultimate uh reality and and
um in a way that's what that that's one
way of understanding what what closure
is trying to do and why I think you know
philosophy uh is essential because we
have to address this crisis of the West
because
it's it is indeed undermining the West
you know there are lots of things about
Western culture which are very very
valuable uh and and approved
um uh beneficial for for many people
doesn't mean to say everything it's
beneficial of course lots of things
aren't but never say there are many
things that were very valuable and there
are alternative accounts in the world
now which don't uh apply those those
principles in quite the same way and we
have to have a basis
um standing in the tradition and we are
we have to about understanding where we
are going with this
and there is a risk that the errors I
think we are making in terms of uh our
understanding of this relationship to
reality uh is is uh vitiating uh the
whole of our culture at some level
um and we're not I think going to Res
you know solve that until we've got an
overall story which works
right and so in the end it is about if
effectively addressing some sort of
problem but yeah you'll probably want to
shy away from the ethical vocabulary
there but it is some kind of an
improvement of some kindness yeah
certainly I think it's it's about
improving the situation we have at the
moment which is a crisis you know crisis
of understanding a crisis of what we
think you know this is these are not
trivial that they they're not just
academic they they bite and as we've
seen in the politics of the last decade
uh they're biting more and more
and they're not you know hiding from the
from the theoretical problem it's not
it's not going to overcome it so I think
we obviously
I think I'm sure there are plenty of
other people who will have uh
alternative uh Frameworks and stories to
the one that I'm putting forward but I
think we have to have some Frameworks to
help us overcome the situation we've got
and give us a sense of
um how we can uh improve and intervene
in the world uh more effectively to
achieve the things that we'd like to
achieve
yeah
okay
um well yes thank you very much